that you're searching for answers, that
quick fix. But here's the truth. That's
not how real growth works. Welcome to
the real conversation we should be
having. Your identity is not what you
achieve. We've been conditioned to
believe our worth comes from external
validation. No one cares about your
story until you win. And even then, most
still don't. Not all friendships are
meant to last forever. The quality of
your five closest friends predicts your
future more accurately than you'd like
to admit. Your company doesn't care
about you. Financial literacy isn't just
important. It's the difference between
freedom and perpetual stress. Your body
is not a rental car. Mental health is
not optional. Seeking help shows
strength, not weakness. The past does
not equal the future unless you choose
to repeat it. Progress matters more than
perfection. These truths won't make you
popular, but they will make you
effective.